[Musique]
elle est là et notre invité politique ce
matin c'est Olivier fort bonjour merci
d'être avec nous bonne année à vous
député de cemar premier secrétaire du
Parti socialiste on est ensemble pendant
20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par Christelle Bertron du
groupe La Dépêche bonjour Christelle
bonjourian bonjour Olivier for bonjour
vous bonne année aussi merci Olivier for
sans surprise on va longuement parler de
la conférence de presse d'Emmanuel
Macron 2h20 c'est la durée de l'exercice
si vous deviez résumer cette conférence
de presse en un mot quel serait-il en TR
tout ça pour
ça je vous rappelle que le Président
nous avait convoqué un grand renfort de
teasing en nous expliquant que ce serait
le grand rendez-vous de la nation qu'il
allait prendre une initiative qui allait
unir les Français qu'a-t-on vu en fait
quelques mesures une grande défiance des
de la jeunesse et puis toujours la même
chose sur les chômeurs que l'on
stigmatise la préférence internationale
qui est parfaitement assumée enfin on a
rien vu qui soit de nature à fédérer le
pays à l'emmener sur une vision sur sur
l'écologie rien ou presque sur la
démocratie rien sur les inégalité
galopante sur le mallogement et cetera
rien on était quand même assez é par la
vacuité du propos on va revenir sur tout
ça en détail vous diriez comme d'autres
que c'était un
bavardage je ne veux pas reprendre une
expression qui vient de Marine Le Pen
mais la réalité c'est que en fait on a
été convoqué sur toutes les chaînes de
télévision un soir à une de grandes
écoutes pour finalement une opération de
communication mais qui n'a rien permis
d'envisager un second souffle pour le
kquena quelque chose qui viendrait
finalement suppler l'absence de campagne
présidentielle du chef de l'État et qui
viendrait dire ce vers quoi il veut
emmener le pays nous a dit je ne sais
pas d'où les gens viennent et je veux
savoir où ils vont enfin c'est plutôt le
Premier ministre qui l'a dit aux
questions d'actualité hier mais où
va-t-il où emmène-t-il le pays personne
n'en sait rien en fait ne croyons pas
que nous allons résoudre le problème
éducatif simplement avec l'uniforme une
cérémonie de remise des diplômes et plus
marseillaise franchement qui peut croire
que ça va remplacer les enseignants qui
manquent ça va permettre de d'assumer ce
que nous avons à assumer pour emmener
une génération à la maturité et donc à
envisager notre avenir avec il a il a
beaucoup parlé de l'école et de la
jeunesse pourquoi vous dites qu'il a
stigmatisé la jeunesse écoutez j'ai
l'impression que il est dans une une
méfiance totale vis-à-vis des plus
jeunes là où il devrai au contraire
stimuler leur imagination leur esprit
d'innovation leur capacité à embrasser
des nouveaux sujets qui sont ceux de
l'avenir mais c'est par qu'ilit lieu de
quoi il nous expliquer en fait qu'il
voulait revenir à la 3e république avec
la blouse et puis la CRÉ au tableau en
fait je vois pas très bien ce qu'il a en
réalité enfin en quoi il a montré la
moindre confiance des plus jeunes qui
sont en fait devenus débiles parce
qu'ils sont devant les écrans et au plus
vieux parce que il faut les mettre en
uniforme pour être sûr que s'assurer de
leur bonne tenue en classe pas favorable
à l'expérimentation de l'uniforme mais
c'est même pas la question la question
question est-ce qu'on pense sérieusement
que le tau d'encadrement des élèves
aujourd'hui est suffisant est-ce qu'on
pense ça c'est un autre sujet mais
est-ce que sur l'uniform vous êtes
favorable ou pas non ce que je dis c'est
que en réalité on a à chaque fois une
espèce de diversion qui est opérée avec
des mesures qui sont censées des mesures
symboliques mais qui ne résolvent rien
si on reprend le débat qui est né avec
Madame oua Castera sur la question du
public et du privé moi j'aimerais que le
Président de la République vienne dire
écoutez le tau d'encadrement désormais
il sera équivalent dans le public et
dans le privé je voudrais qu'il disent
que dans le privé le privé puisqu'il est
quand il est sous contrat il bénéficie à
75 % des subventions de l'État et des
collectivités locales j'aurais aimé
qu'il viennent dire que demain et bien
le privé sera soumis aux mêmes exigences
que le public sur l'accueil des enfants
sur la façon dont on
organise ensemble de leur éducation que
ils disent que le rapport qui est depuis
le mois de juin sur le bureau du
ministre de l'Éducation sur l'école
saislas ou madame cter à ses enfants et
bien ce rapport est un rapport accablant
et qu'il suppose des mesures d'urgence
voilà ce que j'aurais aimé d'un
président qui prend les choses à bras le
corps et qui nous dit voilà j'ai compris
je n'ai pas tout réussi personne ne
réussit tout mais maintenant on y va et
on y met le paquet et y compris sur le
nombre d'enseignants parce que c'est le
nombre d'enseignants en réalité il
diminuent et donc comment voulez-vous
tenir des promesses alors en plus il
nous dit maintenant on aura du théâtre
on aura de l'éducation civique en plus
on aura enfin tout ce que on ne sait
déjà pas faire donc comment est-ce qu'on
le fera demain sans sans en recruter
massivement qu'est-ce que vous appelez
des mesures d'urgence concernant dans
l'école Stanislas et le rapport qui a
été publié donc par meddiapart ce matin
oui alors comme vous le dites publié par
Mediapart et donc qui a été tenu au
secret jusqu'ici pour des raisons qu'on
ignore parce que en réalité ce rapport
il dit quoi il dit que en fait c'est une
école confessionnelle mais vous savez
que pour les écoles privées sous contrat
il n'y a pas d'obligation d'aller subir
enfin subir d'aller à la catéchèse de P
enfin ni d'avoir obligation pour les
offices religieux et cetera ça n'est pas
le cas ça
on nous dit que cet établissement est un
établissement où les propos sexistes
xénophobes par homophobe sont
régulièrement tenu et où en fait rien ne
colle en fait on a une école qui n'est
pas du tout dans les canons de la
républiquece que vous souhaiteriez que
le chef de l'État ou le ministre la
ministre de l'Éducation prenne comme
décision concernant au vu de ce rapport
et concernant cette école B je crois que
si cette école avait été musulmane
depuis longtemps en fait les décisions
auraient été prises les décisions c'est
c'est de mettre sous contrôle d'exiger
en fait un retour au droit commun il n'y
a pas il y a pas
de la religion ben ce que je dis ce que
je remarque c'est que ce rapport il a
été tenu secret pendant en fait de longs
mois et qu'il a fallu que médiia partte
le sorte pour qu'enfin on comprenne
secret parce que c'est une école
catholique pour vous secret parce que
c'est être une école qui a été celle de
Monsieur Blanquer que elle est celle des
enfants de Madame oua ctera et donc qui
il y a une forme d'entre soi ce
gouvernement est un gouvernement où tous
ou presque viennent des mêmes écoles des
mêmes milieux des mêmes quartiers et
sont très très loin en réalité de ce que
sont les réalités des Françaises et des
Français enfin sur l'éducation pour
prendre cet exemple là je viens de le
dire monsieur Blanquer de sanislas
Monsieur papendiaille ses enfants
étaient à l'acienne monsieur hatal a
lui-même été élève à l'aenne et Madame
ctera mais ses enfants privé aussi à
sanislas donc on voit bien que c'est
vraiment l'entre soi la préservation en
fait d'un d'un précarré avec des gens
qui font un choix qui n'est pas un choix
scolaire mais qui est un choix en
réalité de maintenir ou de d'avoir été
maintenu par leurs parents dans un
milieu et de se conformer à des voilà
vous demandez la fermeture de Stanislas
aujourd'hui non je je demande à ce que
le droit commun soit respecté partout en
France y compris dans ces écolesl sur
dernier mot sur éliieou
ctera dire les choses aussi plus
largement toutes les écoles privées
doivent répondre à la carte scolaires
doivent répondre à l'accueil des enfants
qu'elles doivent elles doivent avoir les
mêmes obligations que l'école publiqu
puisqu'elles sont financées par le
public elles doivent avoir des
obligation qui correspondent à ce que le
public doit doit voilà parce que tout
simplement on peut pas avoir un deux POS
de mesure qui ne se justifie pas sur
Amélie ou Castera il a dit qu'elle a eu
raison de s'excuser pour ses propos
maladroits est-ce que pour vous la page
de la polémique est désormais tournée
bah ce serait un peu facile même y
compris quand madame casterra se rend
hier dans l'école litrée euh où
un de ses enfants son éîné a passé 6
mois en maternel voilà ce qui s'est
passé et donc et à partir de là elle a
pu prononcer un espèce de jugement
définitif sur l'école en général l'école
litrée ce n'est pas en fait le Bronx
c'est les enfants déjà des catégories
favorisées puisque c'est lié à
l'arrondissement dans lequel il se situe
et donc elle s'est excusée auprès des
enseignants de litr mais en fait c'est
tous les insignants de France qu'elle
doit maintenant s'adresser et leur dire
qu'elle qu'elle sera en fait une
ministre qui sera qui sera attentive à
l'égalité entre le public et le privé
qui qui fera attention mais vous ne
demandez pas sa démission écoutez je ne
sais pas s'il faut demander sa démission
enfin peu importe la réalité c'est que
moi je les vois tous défiler et qu'ils
font tous la même chose donc ce que je
voudrais c'est que en fait plutôt que de
remplacer les ministres on remplace la
politique qui est menée aujourd'hui un
mot pour finir sur la la la jeunesse
vous parliez de des propos d'Emmanuel
Macron sur les écrans il est revenu à
plusieurs reprises hier soir pour
exprimer son inquiétude de voir les
jeunes passer autant de temps sur les
écrans il promet des mesures par rapport
à ça êtes-vous favorable en effet à une
à une restriction du temps d'écran d'une
manière ou d'une autre j'attends le mode
d'emploi franchement bien sûr que la
question des écrans et il ils sont à la
fois bénéfique d'ailleurs ils ont même
été introduits à l'école euh mais ils
ont aussi le limite et c'est vrai que de
voir des enfants qui sont désormais
complètement captivés par les écrans du
soir au au matin c'est vrai que c'est un
problème mais je ne vois pas très bien
au-delà de l'annonce qu'est-ce qu'il va
faire il va venir derrière chaque
enfant couper les réseaux à telle ou
telle heure enfin j'ai du mal à saisir
c'est irréalisable quoi bah j'ai du mal
à saisir quel est le modus operandi de
cette affaire sur la hausse du prix de
l'électricité qui inquiète les Français
elle est prévue de 10 % le 1er février
est resté un peu flou le chef de l'État
il a dit de côté que la maîtrise des
prix que la MA vous allez nous expliquer
du coup que la maîtrise des prix été
retrouvé mais que il y avait déjà eu
beaucoup d'aide il a parlé de 100
milliards mais en même temps il a laissé
entrreouverte la porte des annonces on
imagine que vous avez pas beaucoup plus
compris que nous est-ce que vous lui
demandez de revenir sur cette hausse
mais bien sûr la réalité c'est qu'il va
compenser la baisse par des taxes c'est
ça qui va se passer mais il laisse la
porte ouverte à des annonces sur
éventuellement
un retour sur ces 10 % en tout cas ce
qu'il a dit
c'est prier ministre le dira dans le
Prain jour voilà c'est le SAL boulot
sera fait par les autres moi je suis là
pour vous dire ben je crois qu'av avoir
compris en fait il nous a expliqué que
le temps des largesse était terminé et
que désormais en fait il fallait revenir
à une orthodoxie budgétaire et que donc
il y aurait une augmentation ça qu'il
nous a dit hier et il ferme pas la porte
à des a éventuellement il a on n pas
compris qu'il avait complètement fermé
la porte par qu'il a renvoyé des
annonces j la dernière aide c'était
l'aide alimentaire qui devait être
annoncé il y avait un chèque alimentaire
qui devait être annoncé par le
gouvernement c'était un engagement du
chef de l'État et le ministre de
l'Économie nous a expliqué il y a
quelques jours que ce chèque était
abandonné la réalité c'est que ils en
ont fini avec toute forme de d'équité ou
de justice et qu'ils sont dans un ils
sont revenus à orthodoxie la plus pure
et que il n'y avait rien de sur le
pouvoir d'achat franchement hier c'était
la misère et même le mensonge s'agissant
du SMIC puisque il nous a expliqué que
le SMIC av augmenté de 20 % où est-ce
qu'il a vu que le SMIC avait augmenté de
20 % c'est 16 % et la réalité c'est que
dans les prix alimentaires pour ne
parler que de ce sujetl c'est plus 25 %
donc où veut-on nous faire croire que
les gens aujourd'hui vivent mieux
qu'hier la réalité c'est qu'aujourd'hui
on a des gens qui il suffit d'aller
faire ses courses dans un supermarché le
weekend pour comprendre que les gens
sont à l'euro près et quand je vois
qu'on va doubler les franchises
médicales euh pour à la fois les
médicaments et les consultations on sait
aussi quell conséquen cela aura cela
aura des conséquences sur l'accès au
soins avec des gens qui se priveront et
qui coûteront finalement plus cher à la
collectivité puisqu'ils viendront plus
tard pour se soigner avec des
pathologies plus graves donc tout ça
relève en fait du calcul à très court
terme et c'est toujours les mêmes qui
payent moi j'aurais aimé que le chef de
l'État nous dise je veux réunir la
nation je parle d'un réarmement civique
ce réarmement civique ça commence par
les plus grands ça commence par le CAC
40 ça commence par ces gens qui viennent
de se mettre 100 milliards dans la poche
et bien je considère que dans un moment
où les crises se cumulent ceux qui ont
le plus doivent contribuer le plus ça ça
aurait été un discours auquel j'aurais
pu adhérer je me serais dit voilà enfin
un président qui a compris que la
cohésion du pays elle repose sur la
justice du coup sur les 10 % vous dites
don Tacte vous n'attendez rien
mais je vais me battre jusqu'au bout
pour qu'au 1er février ce soit pas le
cas mais enfin j'ai compris
l'orientation la pente naturelle du chef
de l'État un dernier émo sur la santé
puisqu'il a demandé la régularisation il
appelle à la régularisation de nombre de
médecins étrangers donc il dit qu'ils
sont indispensables à notre système là
vous applaudissez non mais vous avez vu
en fait c'est le culot du chef de l'État
en fait on est en train d'expliquer que
il faut ne pas régulariser la plupart de
ceux qui sont sur notre sol et qui
pourtant
travaillent sont dans l'emploi et on va
et au nom du fait que trop de gens chez
nous qui viennent de l'étranger et puis
on va seulement capter en fait ceux qui
nous intéresse en fait c'est c'est c'est
la une forme de prédation on dit en fait
que ce don nous avons besoin les
médecins dont on prive ses pays
d'origine et bien eux on va les
régulariser en revanche tous les autres
là
c'estignette ça revient à l'article 4
qui était souhaité par le Président de
la République qui revenait à régulariser
des gens dans les secteurs en tension
pas été vé métiers en tension c'est
d'abord on a jamais connu la liste on ne
sait pas quels sont les métiers qu'il
considèent comme en tenstion et
considère que ce sont pas simplement les
métiers en tension qui doivent être
ouverts à la régularisation mais tous
ceux qui travaillent et qui aujourd'hui
font tourner ce pays qui tiennent ce
pays debout c'est enfin s'il avait fallu
imaginez simplement un instant que on
dise que désormais tous les
étrangers en situation
régulière ou en situation irrégulière
mais qui sont dans l'emploi et bien
devait s'arrêter pendant une
semaine je pense que chacun se rendrait
compte à quel point
du livreur à celui qui fait le ménage à
celui qui s'occupe de nos grands-parents
à celui qui et cetera on s'apercevrait à
quel point en fait nous avons besoin de
ces gens et c'est une façon de les
maintenir dans une forme de de précarité
de l'umpen prolétariat que de renoncer
une fois de plus à les régularisé pour
revenir sur les questions de santé il a
annoncé le doublement des franchises
médicales il a annoncé cette possibilité
de régularisation des médecins étrangers
est-ce que ça va donner ça va pas donner
quand même un peu de souffle
au secteur médical et un peu un peu
d'oxygène mais les MS étrangers sont
déjà là si on veut donner du souffle au
secteur médical il faut embaucher quand
vous voyez en fait ces report lui dit
c'est très long pour faire des médecins
donc il faut s'adapter en attendant oui
enfin je vois surtout en fait que on a
ils ont suppriméus mais qu' a pas plus
de place dans les universités donc en
fait a un numus de fait et que rien
n'est fait pour améliorer la situation
je vois que hôpital se meurt je vois que
en fait on manque partout d'infirmière
d'êre
soignante parce que en fait le métier a
perdu son attractivité qu'on a des gens
qui ont l'impression d'être maltraitant
et que quand on fait ce métier là c'est
une vocation et qu'on a l'impression que
en fait on ne pourra pas s'occuper
raisonnablement des gens dont on a la
charge qu'on r chaque soir en se disant
j'ai mal fait mon boulot quce qu'il fa
faire améli formation améliorer les
salair enfin augmenter les salaires bien
sûr augmenter les salaires bien sûr
recruter faire en sorte que nous soyons
à la hauteur des besoins il y a un
moment où il faut pas prendre les choses
tout le temps à l'envers en se disant
bon j'ai décidé de ne pas prélever sur
les plus riches et sur les grandes
entreprises et donc je vais restreindre
en fait les services publics moi je
préférais qu'on ait le schéma exactement
inverse qu'on se dise quels sont les
besoins pour une vie en collectivité qui
assure la cohésion l'égalité la
possibilité pour chacun de vivre une vie
digne et bien euh si on commence par les
besoins ensuite on a en face ajuster les
moyens on fait exactement l'inverse on
dit voilà quels sont les moyens et
maintenant bah on verra pour les besoins
mais c'est pas le problème c'est pas
c'est pas la bonne façon de procéder
parce que évidemment ça ça crée une
situation où on est très loin du
réarmement des services publics où
est-ce qu'on a vu les services publics
se réarmai comme dit le chef de l'État
nulle part hier le chef de l'État a
démenti tout accord avec Rachid adati
pour la mairie de Paris ce matin sur RTL
elle annonce qu'elle est candidate au
municipal à Paris qu'en dites-vous maisc
en
fait il y a le chef de l'État n'allait
pas annoncer les accords secrets avec
Rchid Dati pour vous il y a eu accord je
vois pas pourquoi rachiti serait venu au
gouvernement s'il n'y avait pas d'accord
on sait bien que l'objectif de sa vie
c'est de conquer cette maie de Paris
donc ça me paraît assez évident que elle
une opportunité fait le fait qu'elle
annonce sa candidature ce matin alors
qu'elle vient tout juste d'être nommé
ministre de la culture c'est
opportunort certainement pas mais qui
est surpris pas vous en tout cas non le
chef de l'État qui s'est dit favorable
au changement du mode de scrutin pour
Paris Lyon Marseille est-ce que les
maires soient élus au suffrage direct et
non pas en direct comme c'est le cas
aujourd'hui Sylvain Maillard a déjà
préparé une proposition de loi à ce
sujet vous la voterez bah on verra quel
est dispositif précis moi je veux pas me
prononcer ce matin il y a des des
raisons qui peuvent pousser à ça et je
veux simplement qu'on s'assure de la
bonne fiabilité et qui est pas
d'entreloupe voilà parce que je je
connais aussi
l'habilité de certains et en fait quand
on touche au mode de scrutin en général
on a une idée derrière la tête et pour
vous la majorité présidentielle a une
idée derrière la tête bah certainement
l'idée effectivement de conquérir un CRE
de mairie et donc je voudrais que on
puisse s'assurer de
de mais ce serait une mauvaise nouvelle
pour la gauche notamment à Paris Mo pas
peur moi je n'ai peur je n'ai peur
d'aucun scrutin je pense que nous
gagneront quel que soi en fait les modes
de scrutin mais je voudrais m'assurer
que tout se passe dans des bonnes
conditions voilà donc j'ai pas de il pas
de de refus de principe c'est simplement
que je veux voir sur pièce voilà
Christel euh alors hier soir euh l'une
des phrases qu'on peut n'a pu retenir
d'Emmanuel Macron et sur le
rassemblement national il a plutôt
épargné la gauche attaqué Jordane
barnella et Marine Le Pen il a eu raison
de parler comme ça il a dit notamment
que c'était le parti de
l'appauvrissement collectif et du
mensonge moi j'aime bien Emmanuel Macron
parce que il se bat contre le RN euh par
intermittence
il se bat contre le RN simplement quand
il y a une élection en vue et qu'il veut
à nouveau se présenter comme le barrage
à l'extrême droite mais désormais qui
peut croire à cette fable depuis le mois
de décembre depuis que le Président de
la République a lui-même avalisé l'idée
de préférence nationale nationale qui a
donné une victoire idéologique au RN
qu'il a été les suivre sur nombre de
sujets comment voulez-v aujourd'hui
qu'il je parle de la loi immigration
évidemment comment voulez-vous
aujourd'hui qu'il viennent nous
expliquer que il est celui qui permettra
de faire barrage aux idées de l'extrême
droite mais lui il voit pas comme ça
vous l'avez entendu hier Olivier fort il
dit que pour lutter contre le
rassemblement national il faut
s'attaquer il faut s'attaquer à ce qu'il
fait voter pour lui et que la lutte
contre l'immigration c'est une réponse
il a pas raison il n'a pas il ne lutte
pas contre l'immigration clandestine
comme il le dit il s'est pris dans ce
projet de loi immigration à la fois à
l'immigration irrégulière et à
l'immigration régulière dans les deux
cas il a été jusqu'à enfin quand on
parle la préférence inter nationale
elles visent qui elles visent des gens
qui sont en situation régulière quand
ils visent le regroupement familial ils
visent des gens qui sont en situation
régulière quand il visent les étudiants
étrangers il fait fait face à des gens
qui sont en situation régulière donc on
n'est pas du tout dans ce qu'il nous
raconte tout le monde est contre les
passeurs tout le monde est contre
l'explitation de euh des humains qui
sont euh qui fuit la misère ou la guerre
donc on est dans une situation où le
chef de l'État a donné une victoire
idéologique au RN et où maintenant il
voudrait nous faire croire qu'il est le
barrage non c'est pas vrai et donc quand
il nous dit en plus que il va renvoyer
le sale boulot en fait au Conseil
constitutionnel pour venir euh
détricoter la loi là il est dans une
situation où il est même fascinant de
voir un chef de l'État qui accepte de
faire voter des dispositions qu'il sait
antionstitutionnell et qui vont ouvrir
un débat au lendemain de la décision du
Conseil pu que Lauran Fabius a pointé
entre la souveraineté populaire du
Parlement et puis le gouvernement des
juges qui sera dénoncé par la droite et
par l'extrême droite donc il va ouvrir
une crise y compris sur ce qui est notre
État de droit quelle est cette
irresponsabilité présidentielle Olivier
fort ça veut dire que si demain il y
avait un second tour qui opposait
Emmanuel Macron et Marine Le Pen vous
n'appelleriez plus à voter Emmanuel
Macron pour faire barrage pour
rassemblement pas là en tout cas c'est
même quoi que je dise enfin les Français
de toute façon aujourd'hui ont une
attitude qui
très sans doute j'espère mais enfin la
réalité c'est que je vois des gens que
je rencontre chaque jour chaque semaine
ma circonscription qui me disent mais
mais vous nous avez fait voter pour
Emmanuel Macron ce qui est vrai j'ai
appelé à voter Emmanuel Macron au
deuxième tour il me disent mais mais si
c'était pour qu'il fasse comme Marine Le
Pen en fait quelle est la différence
quel est l'intérêt quel est le sujet sur
lequel en fait donc vous ne le referiez
pas je n'ai je on en est pas là parce
que la réalité c'est qu'il y aura
quelqu'un de gauche au deuxème tour face
à Marine Le Pen et que nous battons mar
Marine Le Pen mais voilà je je je je dis
simplement que pour les élections
européennes c'est le grand objectif de
cette conférence de presse di d'Emmanuel
Macron et bien plutôt que d'aller
chercher à trouver en fait dans celui ou
celle qui sera désigné par Emmanuel
Macron pour conduire cette campagne
qu'il mènera d'ailleurs lui-même et bien
choisissez plutôt une liste qui est
celle qui sera conduite par Raphael
gluxman et qui permettra là de faire non
seulement barrage à l'extrême droite
mais barrage aussi à idées parce que le
problème ce n'est pas de combattre le RN
en reprenant ce qu'il dit c'est
d'arriver à combattre le RN en refusant
ce qu'il propose est-ce qu'auudelà des
européennes vous espirez profiter de
cette droitisation du gouvernement et
est-ce que pour récupérer les électeurs
de gauche déçu d'Emmanuel Macron il font
pas que vous rompiez définitivement avec
Jean-Luc Mélenchon non mais d'abord je
ne profite de rien en fait moi je
cherche pas à profiter je cherche à ce
que les Français puisse vivre dans un
pays dans lequel l' rison républicain
est toujours l'objet objectif et où
chaque jour on cherche à parfaire en
fait cet idéal hier Emmanuel Macron a
repris le slogan qui est celui qui a été
celui d'ericiioti de de voquier de de
Zemour qui est pour que la France reste
la France mais ce ce slogan sans en fait
le conservatisme le plus total en fait
on n pas demandé à ce que la France
reste la France on a à demandé à ce que
la France devienne la France au sens où
l'idéal républicain est un idéal qui
n'est jamais atteint il faut toujours
avancer davantage chaque jour faire en
sorte qu'on puisse avoir plus d'égalité
plus de liberté plus de fraternité c'est
ça l'objectif sur le PS et donc sur le
PS est-ce que c'est une bonne nouvelle
pour vous ou pas mais c'est une mauvaise
nouvelle pour les Français d'abord et
donc nous nous allons faire notre devoir
et chercher à ça ve dire vous appelez
pas les électeurs de gauche déçu
d'Emmanuel Macron à vous rejoindre bien
sûr que j'appelle celles et ceux qui ont
loyalement qui ont sincèrement cru
qu'Emmanuel Macron pouvait être l'homme
du en même temps qu'il pouvait être
celui qui permettait de de consolider
d'approfondir le modèle social français
et qui s'aperçoivent après la réforme
des retraites après la loi immigration
après la réforme de l'assurance chômage
après la réforme du RSA se rendre compte
que il est tout sauf ça et bien
effectivement qu'il revienneent vers des
formations politiques qui elles ont de
toute leur histoire et de toutes leur
tripe fait ce choix-là celui d'assumer
l'idéal républicain mais est-ce que pour
cela Jean-Luc Mélenchon n'est pas un
repoussoir d'où je vous repose ma
question est-ce que si vous voulez
récupérer ces électeurs et les ramener
vers vous il faut pas romprer avec
Jean-Luc Mélenchon mais j'ai déjà dit
com sur V plateau ce que je pensais de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon qu'il était devenu en
fait lui qui avait été le meilleur
représentant de la gauche à deux
reprises à l'élection présidentielle
qu'il était celui qui faisait baissé le
plafond de verre au-dessus de nos têtes
et que nous avons besoin non pas
seulement de quelqu'un qui peut
performer sur le premier tour mais de
quelqu'un qui puisse permettre de
rassembler jusqu'à 51 % des voix pour
battre l'extrême droite et c'est ça
l'objectif Christ dernière question
calendrier on nous attend on nous
annonce pardon un discours de politique
générale du Premier ministre le 30
janvier euh et la suite du remanement
début février est-ce que pour vous c'est
le bon timing bah écoutez je vous laisse
juge mais enfin franchement on est on
est un peu embarrassé de d'accabler ce
pauvre Premier ministre qui vient à
peine d'arriver mais quand même enfin le
chef de état qui convoque la France
entière à 20h et lui qui est renvoyé au
calandre grec pour vir présenter son
discours de politique général avec un
gouvernement qui sera complété que dans
la foulée enfin tout
ça ça ça au moins un mérite ça permet de
rappeler que Jupiter reste Jupiter et
que le pouvoir reste concentré dans les
mains du seul chef de l'État et qu'il a
nommé un porte-parole dernière question
bis gabrielal qui a dit hier qu'il
solliciterait pas de vote de confiance
surura une motion de censure du PS mais
bien sûr c'est c'est une évidence en
fait moi j'aurais tellement aimé que
dans ce grand rendez-vous de la nation
le chef de l'État dise j'en revient à la
lettre des institutions c'est le
gouvernement qui conduit la politique de
la nation et qui vient chercher une
majorité à l'Assemblée et donc je
souhaite que Gabriel Attal Vienne devant
l'assemblée présente son projet et se
soumet le soumett au vote majorité c'est
ce qu'on fait avec toute la gauche donc
ce sera unetion deanup ave ah benah avec
l'ensemble de la gauche parce que elle F
compris bien sûr avec toute la gauche
parce que il y a aujourd'hui des
convergences quand je dis que je ne suis
pas d'accord avec tout ce que dit
Jean-Luc Mélenchon et tout ce que
peuvent faire les insoumis ça ne veut
pas dire que ça ne veut pas dire que je
n'ai aucune convergence avec eux la
gauche reste la gauche et il y a des
désaccords mais il y a aussi
heureusement des points d'accord et en
l'occurrence sur le fait qu'un premier
ministre dans une grande démocratie doit
venir chercher sur la base de son projet
une majorité regardez ce qui s'est passé
en Espagne C ces derniers mois et bien
là-dessus nous sommes entièrement
d'accord et nous sommes parfaitement
convergents voilà merci merci beaucoup
d'avoir été notre invité c'est Emmanuel
Macron évidemment la Une de La Dépêche
Christ le général
Macron le choisi par la dépêche merci
CHR à la semaine prochaine on continue à
parler d'Emmanuel Macron dans le club